And it was great.
I can do anything I want.
Not caring about trends.
Not caring about optimization.
And I'm so excited.
In the wrong way, turn around.
I'm having so much fun, though.
I'm having a lot of fun.
Just doing YouTube completely incorrectly.
Uh-oh.
Just playing whatever the hell I want.
This is what I like.
And if you don't like it, well, whatever.
We're all in this together.
Hello, hello, my name is Amelie, also known as Monarch.
I found a friend around like 13 or 14 years old.
At school, I found this friend at lunch, and she was like
going through anime, and secretly, I had been watching anime
on TV.
Like, it was really cool, so it was fun to just find a
friend that had that weird interest like mine.
We wouldn't go play outside.
Outside?
in the Florida humidity?
Disgusting!
Absolutely not.
We would make tea, we would cover salts, and we would just
have fun.
Hello, my name is Iron Mouse.
So I was a very big nerd when I was a teenager.
I was of poor health growing up, so I spent a lot of time
indoors, and my mom also was very adamant that I studied
while I was sick, so as soon as I was done, I needed to look
for an escape.
When I would come home from school, I mostly just watched
anime and listened to music and studied.
I felt like I was trapped in a box a lot of times throughout
my life because I felt like the world was moving on without
me.
So I was more like looking outside at the world than when I
would go online.
I felt like I was transported into the world and I felt like
I could forget about Issues.
My name is Jokie Bird.
So I am a huge perfectionist.
I want everyone to like me.
Like I'm such a people pleaser.
And I would get, you know, I would get close to teachers.
And I would go to like, what's it called, like office hours.
Because I was like, I'm going to suck up to these teachers.
I'm going to be teacher's pet.
But then on my last two years at university, I rediscovered
gaming.
So I just hope I was like, oh, I should do my homework.
but I could play Overwatch right now.
So it got really bad in my last two years just because it
was like really good GPA.
And then you can tell when I started playing video games
again and then okay GPA.
I was like, as long as I pass.
My name is Rin Penrose.
It's either that or John V.
Tuber.
Take your pick.
I spend a lot of my free time playing video games.
Listen, video games are for escapism.
Video games are great.
What was this interview about again?
My first cover that actually got big was Crossing Field.
I was actually in college at the time I was working retail,
just barely making rent.
And I remember I had gotten my check from YouTube for ad
rev, and it was more that I had made at my job.
I can quit my job and do this thing that I have loved doing
for so long.
And I remember telling my parents, and they were like, no,
no, no, no, no.
This music thing's not gonna work out, so you have to have a
backup plan.
Please keep your real job.
And I was like, no, like, this is what I wanna do.
Like, this is what I do, like, in my closet, in my room for
so many hours.
It's my love.
The way I do videos normally is a terrible garbage premise.
What's the trending game this week?
Ignore that.
I do not care.
You have to kind of look outside of what everyone in your
circle is already doing, if you want any hope of being
original.
You just have to be delusional off to believe that your idea
is worth something.
It's like fake it till you make it, right?
So I didn't really know what a VTuber was when I became a
VTuber.
So the moment my artist finished the retro Doki skin suit, I
would like put it on, I was like, live.
I was like, hey guys, I'm on the screen now.
They were like, whoa!
When V2 Bean became a thing, I remember being like, I can
become an anime girl on the internet.
Wait a second.
I can be the anime on the TV.
That's incredible.
I kind of wanted to try live streaming, but I did not have
the confidence.
And I had a friend that told me, have you ever thought about
maybe using a virtual avatar to stream?
and I looked into Kizuna Ai and I instantly became a fan of
hers and I thought she was incredible and she was so funny
and so cute.
I think V-Tubing is like a good medium for self-expression.
If you're unhappy with your body, congratulations, you're
anime now.
I woke up like this, it's incredible, because you're kind of
freed of, you know, a lot of the physical factors in the
real world.
You can be whatever you want, as long as it's anime.
I remember when I was choosing uh who i wanted to be i kept
thinking about what am i and the concept of a cute loving
demon i i felt like that would be very cute i don't know i
feel devilish i guess you could say inside when i redid my
concept art as a devil as a demon queen i felt like that is
me that is myself i remember getting ready to debut and
stuff and they're like oh what concept do you want to have
And I was kind of thinking right, because there are two
archetypes you see quite a lot.
We're going to call them small girl and grown woman who
should know better.
And I'm quite openly Aeroace.
I don't really mess with any of that stuff.
I am Aeroace, and if you disrespect me, I have clearance to
evaporate you on site.
Clearance from whom?
Me.
Stupid?
So I decided that instead of my content kind of leaning
toward that, I'm just going to be a real silly little dude.
That's all there is for it.
Jokingly, I also call Monarch my Barbie because I get to
dress her up in all of these very cool outfits.
And I feel like I spend more money on her outfits than my
own in-person.
But it's all worth it because she's queen.
We have to, right?
I am quite pleased by the fact that...
I just kind of ignored all of the conventional rules.
You know, be super girly, be like emotionally intimate with
your audience and stuff.
You don't really have to kind of conform to the trends if
you don't want to in order to be successful.
Now, the thing here is that I really banked on being
successful, but damn it, it worked.
I actually considered retiring music.
I was actually... I was kind of bored doing covers, I'm not
gonna lie.
so many years and I wasn't getting the same feeling doing
covers because I was just doing the same formulaic thing
over and over again working by myself.
I always thought, oh I wish there was something that I could
do that would be fun, that would help me make new people and
I could possibly connect with more people.
And so when V-tubing came around that kind of lit the fire
again.
And so for Monarch because it felt like a new chapter I
really wanted to showcase what I could do as a as a
songwriter as well, so that was very important to me.
I wanted to write original stories and write like fantasy
novels.
That was a dream of mine.
And so actually VTubing was an extension of that.
I get to create a character and a story and a lore like I
wanted to do when I was an English major, but now transition
it into music.
So it was like a perfect puzzle piece.
It's kind of crazy how it all came together that way.
Through my VTubing journey, I've been able to take back my
life almost.
B-Tubing was my second chance at life.
Because not only did it give me more friends, I was able to
start earning a living.
And I was able to take care of myself better.
Sometimes I feel like I should.
I should take a break.
But I feel like I have so much time I need to make up for.
And I have so much to do.
And so much that I want to do.
Because I spent so much time.
not doing anything that I feel like I have to catch up to
like a normal person.
I hate like just coasting along and I feel like I always
wanna do something.
I wanna do something cool, I wanna do something fun because
streaming is not like a long-term career.
I think everyone knows that.
One week in real life is like 20 years on the internet.
So, because like people like, you know, we have very short
attention spans now, including me, I have very short
attention span.
So all of the stuff that's happening right now is very
unbelievable to me, let alone and being like on a stage and
performing and singing again.
I feel like I'm going to wake up from a dream any minute now
and I'm gonna be back to where I was before.
But I hope it's not and I hope that it's real life.
I love collabing with other musicians, bouncing off ideas
and creating something together.
One song on my original album, Rise of the Monarch that I
really love so much is Villain Vibes, which is actually
featuring Mori Calliope.
We were chatting.
I was like, crazy idea.
I know we said we wanted to do something together in the
future.
How about now?
She told me that she was really inspired by my work and that
she liked me a lot and wanted to collaborate together.
And I was like, really?
With me?
That's a dream come true.
Actually, she wrote her own rap because I wanted it to be
authentic to her.
When I first heard the song, I was immediately like, oh wow,
that's really, that's a high-quality song.
So I feel like the combination of our energies, we really
synergized very well, I think.
And that song is just like so, can I say badass, badass?
And it just makes me feel like so empowered every time I
listen to it.
And fans will come up to me and they're like, oh, it's on my
workout playlist.
And I'm like, yeah, gains, gains.
There's so many concerts and so many fun live performances
that I've been doing.
There's, oh, let me think.
I'm thinking, I'm thinking, I'm thinking.
I'm gonna be able to perform in Puerto Rico, my home.
My mom would be so excited and so overjoyed that she just
starts screaming saying, oh, that's my daughter, that's my.
You know, there's so many accolades in terms of like being
able to do a concert, being the most subscribed Twitch
streamer.
But for me personally, I think the one that I'm most proud
of is just watching Mouse's kind of health get a lot better.
Even now, she's been walking, which was not even in the
picture before.
She's eating food now, which she wasn't before.
It's like going live and putting on a great show, throwing
concerts, raising millions of dollars for charity.
And it's really fun to play around in general because it's
like your world building.
And it's like a little fun event I can do too for it.
Like it's fun.
I am so honored to get to do what I do.
It's not work to me.
It's fun.
Me, I'm going to be doing some very dumb stuff in the
future, hopefully.
And I'd say look forward to it.
And I just have.
When I first came back after everything, I literally thought
my career was over.
I can't do it, I can't do it.
It was so hard, it was so hard.
Please God make this work.